heute könnte sich maria callas zukunft
entscheiden
zwei bewerbungen an einem tag bei einem
familienunternehmen bewirbt sich mayotte
als paket auslieferer damit er
unbefristet in deutschland bleiben kann
muss er neben guten deutschkenntnissen
auch einen job oder eine ausbildung
nachweisen
[Applaus]
beim bewerbungsgespräch müssen wir
draußen warten 2015
magath kommt als 17 jähriger aus syrien
nach deutschland
er ist einer von mehr als 58.000
unbegleiteten minderjährigen
flüchtlingen die in den kommenden zwei
jahren asylanträge stellen werden in
einer erste unterkunft in fürth fängt er
ein neues leben an
job nebenbei als kellner und besucht
einen sprachkurs weit weg vom krieg in
der heimat
[Musik]
die stadt hama heißt zum mittelpunkt der
gewalt geworden es ist ein krieg der
jede woche hunderte neuer opfer fordert
augenzeugen sprechen von einem blutbad
die eltern und sechs geschwister bleiben
in syrien
sie flüchten später in die türkei heute
lebt in nürnberg und zeigt ehrgeiz beim
bewerbungsmarathon ob er sich beim
vorstellungsgespräch behaupten konnte
war dass das interessiert strukturiert
und was mir aufgefallen seine sprache
ist fantastisch also spricht einem am
freitag und ich glaube er hat chancen
weil er die finger hatte hat auch wenig
gezeigt sie waren sehr sympathisch und
so viel mit meinem vorstellungsgespräch
und sie haben mir angeboten ein broker
tag zu machen und nach dem probetag wir
entscheiden ob das arbeitsstelle für
mich ist oder nicht
die zweite bewährungsprobe direkt im
anschluss probearbeiten bei einer auto
reinigung nach einem jahr hätte er damit
sogar die chance auf eine ausbildung
das ist unsere fahrzeuge führung
hast du den typ schon erkannt was für
ein wenig zu das ist ein gran turismo 3
für magath als auto kennen könnte das
der beginn eines großen traums sein
doch geputzt hat er so einem sportwagen
noch nie kann er trotzdem glänzen
freiburg im breisgau hier sind zehn
prozent der auszubildenden im handwerk
geflüchtete in der gemeinnützigen
werkstatt p3 werden einige von ihnen in
einer einstiegsqualifizierung für die
ausbildung fit gemacht hast du die
scharfe kanten noch ein bisschen stärker
so ist das jetzt eigentlich überall
schon weg drost smi kam 2016 aus eritrea
nach deutschland ebenfalls ohne eltern
und als minderjähriger er ist jetzt im
zweiten lehrjahr schreiner ist gute job
und da einfach so nach der hauptschule
ausbildung
damals war ein bisschen schwer aber gehe
nach dem einstieg golf ist leichter
geworden
damals war ein bisschen die sprache
nicht gut kenne ja jetzt ist im p3 habe
ich so viele nach helfer wirkungen nun
mein deutsch auch verbessert und ich
denke jetzt ist klar
direkt nach der arbeit gibt es hier
deutsch und mathe stunden was in der
praxis unklar war kann nach besprochen
werden
für die ausbilder ist aber noch etwas
entscheidend die leute die hier sind
haben dann auch bock aufs handwerk und
hat dementsprechend motiviert geht es
dann auch in der werkstatt voran
die menschen kommen aus so vielen
verschiedenen ländern und bringen so
viele unterschiedliche weltsichten oder
auch herausforderungen mit p3 gründer
david rösch engagiert sich seit zehn
jahren in der flüchtlingshilfe was mich
oft frustriert hat ist halt einfach auch
zu sehen in welchen verbinden dilemma
situation
menschen mit luft oder
migrationserfahrung und wie schwer es
dann für sie zum teil ist halt wirklich
ihre füße auf dem boden hier zu bekommen
mit allen negativen konsequenzen jahren
natürlich daraus entstehen jetzt
vielleicht nicht bekommen dass er es
hinbekommen muss hat sich viel
vorgenommen
one day eines tages werde ich es
schaffen
hast du jeder hier hat sein päckchen zu
tragen auch wenn er nicht darüber
sprechen möchte
aber jeder im team wird akzeptiert und
hat später gute aussichten auf dem
arbeitsmarkt in nürnberg geht für maria
kein langer probetag zu ende
das hast du gemacht hast sehr gut alle
schritte richtig genau so stellen wir
uns das vor und ich freue mich darauf
das praktikum noch zu machen und dann
ganz offiziell
damit liegen zwei jobangebote auf dem
tisch deutschland als land der
unendlichen möglichkeiten
solange man sich verständigen kann in
die arbeit habe ich schwierigkeiten
vielleicht mit dem sprache weil sie
hatten akzent die leute wo ich mich halt
noch mal fragen wie bitte darin die
leute nur auf fränkisch gesprochen
zum glück hatte ich auch eine ein
kollege der es noch nicht geboren hat
der hat auch die sprache kommen hier
gelernt und er hat nicht schritt für
schritt beigebracht was das heißt was
das heißt dass das heißt auf englisch
englisch und auf deutsch
zurück zu hause die ersten eigenen vier
wände bedeutet auch selbstständig werden
fünf jahre alleine muss man was lernen
alleine gucken gibt keine mutter mehr
aber die wäre sicherlich stolz auf mich
ich bin auf einem bauernhof aufgewachsen
deswegen mag ich die pflanzen zu machen
und hält die einstellung wie sie
aufwachsen das ist so geil
also dass ich genauso wie meine kleine
kinder
das bringt mich eigentlich zurück nur zu
meinen alte zeiten halt also wo ich
daheim war ja ich bin seit fünf jahren
hier ungefähr
und ich kenne alle meine kumpels sind
hier auch ich kenne die straßen so ist
schon bei zeugt heimat kann man sagen
halt auch seinen jüngsten bruder wollte
magath einen neuanfang ermöglichen
doch dann wurde man volljährig und
konnte ihn laut gesetz nicht mehr nach
deutschland holen
er hofft dass die familie irgendwann
wieder zusammen sein kann
doch jetzt ist er bereit für die zukunft
und die vergangenheit gut in einem
aktenordner
warum sollte ich in deutschland treffen
was denkst du wenn du dich sie ist vor
fünf jahren ja dass ich das bin ich
nicht das sieht nach einer andern wenn
ich also dabei kaputt nachdem flucht
wirkung das alles hinter mir sind alle
ist jetzt vergangenheit und jetzt kann
man was halt anfangen ohne daran zu
erinnern also und ich hoffe das passiert
auch nicht noch mal dass man sich
nochmal fluchten musste und wieder ein
neues leben anfangen sonst wird das
schwer
für murat zählt das jetzt und das
beginnt mit einem neuen job als autor
einiger er ist angekommen nach fünf
jahren in deutschland
[Musik]